hello guys I'm Ryan right
I'm Jerry we're gonna check out the
official red band trailer for
moonwalkers sorry Rupert Grint
and Ron Perlman yeah Branagh no more
team no I don't know what this is at all
me or do I
which would be cooler if this is the
actors new ROM bloody violence and
graphic nudity and plentiful drug deeds
watch you've been many our eleventh
Apollo mission to the moon in 10 days
time whether things gonna make it or not
if the Russians happen to make it to the
moon first we're gonna wind up looking
like a bunch of dicks so here's the plan
meet with Cooper
convincing you know landing as if you're
on the phone we have a proposal for mr.
Kubik
there's a considerable amount of money
in this project five minutes to be
Stanley Kubrick we decided that it's not
one man in the world that could pull
this off and that man is
oh [ __ ]
what's the true story
kubrick I paid a visit to continental
Europe
not sure to either huh
do you reading when I go back to your
boss you telling me you don't have
standing to breathe and you don't have
the month we must be the only hope
you've got
[ __ ] now is not a saint he wants to
know if you'd be interested to making a
film innings in seven days she is a
director if we doubled your
whoa Jesus
right
I see is the best thing for headaches
I'm cia-trained my mind is too strong
for that [ __ ] Wow I'm on board that
looks nuts that looks insane in all the
right ways especially by the end yet cuz
like the first half of the trailer at
least I was like this looks like it's a
true one of those true stories that
wants to be really cool there like that
so I was like ok this could go either
way and then it went crazy and I was
like I think that could if all those
three meet that could be [ __ ] awesome
like the bizarreness of that world it
seems so much fun to explore yeah and
the story behind it
I really like to you to say I mean I
didn't know that story prior I don't
know much well I mean there's always
been speculation there's a confirmed
conspiracy that we think some people
believe that the moon landing never
actually happened and they filmed it on
a stage and they put it on TV to like
increase American morale during the Cold
War some people think that we just
filmed and it never actually happened
and other people are like you're an
idiot we did go to the moon yes I liked
the idea of exploring the story and
seemed like all the craziness go down
with the debauchery and then what really
hooked me was what's although [ __ ]
violence about when I was seeing that
[ __ ] I was like what the [ __ ] is going
on there is that one point they have a
shot in the trailer he just blows off
the guy's head and it's like first you
don't really know where tentacle
creature yeah what cuz it's so fast
you're not expecting I almost feel like
at that point it's just like oh uh you
know it's like an etch-a-sketch and I
like that kind of manic behavior it
looks like it's a hybrid of like one of
those cool like we were saying earlier
like a cool biopic or cool true story
yeah combined with like a little bit of
George Miller chaos they're like infused
in the mix a little bit you know basem
surreal cuz like the first minute I kept
finding myself going like I hope
whatever this movie is showing me I hope
they give me a bit more
I get there yeah because the whole movie
is just this tone be alright but if it
does something extra that's what I want
that's what seems like the back half did
cuz it's so over the top it's so surreal
looking at least in the brief glimpses
like a locally rerun if you're an
expressive yet because I mean the rating
for it is plentiful drug use so oh yeah
I'm going to assume and see you rob
Pearlman and Rupert Grint and these
roles first off great for Rupert Grint
to be doing a role separately from Ron
Weasley and you know some other roles
but still like this is could be a big
one for him I hope this works cuz I
think he could be a really collector
like you know if he can break out of
being wrong
yeah and same thing for Ron Perlman yeah
it means like tough guy in the movie of
course but still it's wrong Pearlman who
we know from like Hellboy and Sons of
Anarchy but this looks like a different
kind of character that I could totally
get on board with cuz he's a great actor
well yeah and he's he's got enough
seniority now you know he's an older guy
now he can pull off not just being a
tough guy but being a you know a more
grounded version of that character it's
like we believe it's not a stretch he
doesn't look like he's just a tough guy
he looks like a full human being in this
yeah he looks like a stern guy or maybe
a responsible guy not like oh he's
totally gonna beat you down right now
yeah exactly he looks like the guy who
could figure his way out of a situation
and you know throw down if you had to
I'm excited for it I am - it looks
pretty like it's like the first semi
kubrick story told anyway guys thanks
for tuning into the channel if for you
today subscribe today and become a
reject click this button this but
reasons to Jerry dank ass dubs on this
channel check out those playlists follow
us on our social networks listen we got
a product placement coming up soon we're
gonna be doing a shout out to a company
watch that video hit the like button
because I could get future deals within
yeah you could if everyone likes the
video so you'll know when it's being
promoted you'll know what product it is